honey it's time for bed hold on mom it's
the series finale of The Secret World of
Alex Mack and there's only five minutes
left now you have school tomorrow
morning I never got to see the series
finale of The Secret World of Alex Mack
funny thing is I actually met her a few
years ago because we went to the same
acting studio and so I asked her how did
this series end and then she said
actually it was a cliffhanger Oh life
how you tease me so do you ever get like
really really really into TV shows
sometimes I get so into a TV show that I
forget it's fiction like I remember this
one time I literally thought the entire
cast of friends were actually my friends
although that might have been the acid I
get so consumed by media sometimes like
Family Guy homeland lost The Walking
Dead don't even get me started on The
Walking Dead ray hates watching TV with
me cuz I'm like you know one of those
people are you doing you never know
where Carl and I'll get it why would he
do that wrong with you oh my god now I'm
sure some of you are like Oh TV rots
your brain
wrap it up around but honestly I think
it's so amazing that we can be so
emotionally invested in something that
essentially came from someone's
imagination I used to do background on
the show house and sometimes they would
screen completed episodes for us during
lunch and I remember sitting there
thinking like wow I was a part of this I
may not have been a big part but I was a
part in making this and it was a
wonderful feeling so the next time you
feel that way I hope that you get
involved I feel like our generation in
particular is just so apathetic and
judgmental and cruel for no reason I
feel like we've all forgotten what it's
like to be a part of a community
and to support each other's creations
and dreams and to really recognize and
appreciate all the hard work that goes
into creating art
creating anything for that matter or
even just being a fucking human being
that's enough of a mind fuck as is so
they'll me a lot to think of my latest
look okay honestly I can I can see that
you've put a lot of time and effort into
this piece as well as some firsthand
research based on those purple veins
I see protruding there but I would be
doing you a disservice if I didn't tell
you that it's not your best and I think
you can do better
oh you Americans you don't know oft what
a good penis venue subhan so yeah stay
awesome Gotham